[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ويرجى إرسال تحياتنا إلى SAR
تحياتي الكثيرة
شكرا لك الآن للحظة، يا عزيزي
الناس لفترة وجيزة ل
expiration0 الناس في واحد
صباحا للتعبير عن
الطلب فوري
الهدنة
في غزة
وتحدثت للتو وأيضا
قدم الدعوة العالمية الآن
من قبل ما يقرب من 500 ممثل في جميع أنحاء العالم
أ
الهدنة وأيضا لديها شيء
وجدت بضع كلمات حول هذا الموضوع
دعوى الإبادة الجماعية في الحاج
جنوب أفريقيا قدمت لي
نظرت إليها عن كثب وأنا
كما أرحب بهذه المبادرة لأنني
أعتقد أنه من المهم تقديم هذه الادعاءات
لمتابعة كل ذلك هو ما لدي هنا
[تصفيق]
قال لذلك أنا هنا اليوم لأنني
يريد إظهار التضامن مع فلسطين
أجد أنه من المحزن أن الناس لديهم
العيون لا
ألمانيا تنفتح الآن
وأعتقد أيضا أن المحكمة تتدخل
حزين
أشعر بالخجل لأنني فعلت ذلك
جواز السفر الألماني لذلك أنا موجود
أساسا الألمانية وأنا أشعر بالخجل
وآمل أن يكون هذا هو الحال للأسف
أعتقد أن الحرب ستتوقف أخيراً
ومن الرائع أن جنوب أفريقيا لديها الآن إسرائيل هناك
حاول أن يحاسب
وآمل أن ينتهي هذا أخيرًا
يجلب إسرائيل الرد على
استقلال فلسطين وفيها بالتحديد
وإذا كانت هناك مشكلة، فماذا عليهم أن يفعلوا؟
ثم يفعل الفلسطينيون ذلك
على سبيل المثال